The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANDREW LO: OK.
What I'd like to do today is
to continue where we left off
last time in talking about this
risk-reward trade-off, which
ultimately will allow us
to be able to figure out
how to calculate the proper
discount rate for any project
under the sun.
Now, where we left off last time
was this equation and the one
after it.
This equation we
actually derived.
I showed you how to
get this equation
from this particular bullet
and the tangency line.
And today I am going to
give you names for them.
The bullet, as we've said
before, is the frontier.
It's the set of
frontier portfolios.
And the upper arc
of that bullet is
called the efficient frontier.
Now the tangency line
has a special name too.
That tangency line is known
as the capital market line
because it represents what
all efficient capital markets
should represent in terms
of risk-reward trade-off.
So if you are an efficient
portfolio manager,
you want to be on that line.
OK?
So the capital market
line, the equation
for that tangency
line, is given by this.
The expected rate of return
is equal to the risk-free rate
plus some kind of risk
premium, where the risk premium
is given by a multiple of
the market's risk premium,
or the market excess return.
And the multiple
is simply the ratio
of the riskiness of
your efficient portfolio
relative to the
market portfolio,
or the tangency portfolio.
If it's twice as
risky, you're going
to get twice the risk premium.
If it's half as
risky, you're going
to get half the risk premium.
And we said last
time that, while this
is helpful and interesting
and even possibly useful,
it's going to be of
limited applicability
because not everything is
an efficient portfolio.
What we mean by an
efficient portfolio,
the intuition for what an
efficient portfolio is,
is a portfolio where
you cannot do better.
By cannot do better, I mean you
can't get less risk for that
same level of return, or you
can't get more expected return
for that same level of risk.
That's what we mean by
an efficient portfolio.
It's the best you can do.
Now, most investments are,
frankly, not efficient.
If you pick an arbitrary
stock, like IBM, that's
not an efficient portfolio.
It doesn't mean it's no good.
It doesn't mean you
don't want to hold it.
But it means that
you would never
want to hold just IBM because if
you mixed IBM with other stuff,
you can always do better.
By do better, again
I'm going to reiterate,
I mean you can have
higher expected return
for the same level of risk or
lower risk for the same level
of expected return.
That's what I mean by do better.
So you would never want
to hold IBM just by itself
because you can
do better, right?
You can do better in getting
up to that Northwest quadrant
from the IBM point.
But even though IBM
is not efficient,
you might still want to hold it.
And more importantly,
you might still
want to know what the
appropriate discount
rate is for companies
that are like IBM.
That's what we're
going to do next.
Where I left off last time was
not the capital market line,
but this equation, which I did
not derive, but which I argued
comes from the
equilibrium argument
that Bill Sharpe
made 50 years ago.
And this really
relies on the fact
that, if markets
are in equilibrium,
there is a relationship
between risk
and expected return for
all securities, not just
efficient portfolios.
But any arbitrary security
has to satisfy this equation
if supply equals demand,
if there's an equilibrium.
If everybody holds the
tangency portfolio,
and the tangency
portfolio therefore
is the market portfolio,
in that situation,
this equation has to hold.
So where we left off was to
try to interpret this equation.
This equation is almost
identical to the capital market
line.
There's only one difference.
The only difference is that
the multiplier, the thing that
multiplies the
market risk premium,
is not sigma p over sigma m.
It is beta.
And beta, we said, was the
ratio of the covariance
of an asset with
the market divided
by the variance of the market.
It is a measure of that
particular asset's riskiness.
It's not variance anymore,
or standard deviation,
it's something else.
And so I want to spend
this class talking
about what that something else
is and why it makes sense.
First of all, let's make sure
we understand the equation.
I want to do a
few special cases,
and then I'm going to take
apart this notion of beta
as being the right measure
of risk in all circumstances.
So the first thing I want to
do is to look at some examples.
Let's take an example where
the beta is equal to 1.
If the beta is equal to
1, what that's saying
is that the covariance between
the asset and the market
divided by the
variance of the market,
that number is equal to 1.
If that's the case,
then it turns out
that the expected rate of return
of this asset with a beta of 1
is going to be just equal
to the market risk premium.
Or the expected return is
equal to the market's expected
rate of return.
When beta is equal to
1, the Rf's cancel out,
and the expected rate
of return of the asset
is equal to the expected
rate of return on the market.
Now, what about if the
beta is equal to 0?
If the beta is equal to 0, then
you get the risk-free rate.
It's important to realize
that if the beta of an asset
is equal to 0, it doesn't
mean that the asset has
no volatility.
In the past, when
we've looked at mixing
the risk-free asset,
T-bills, with the market,
we know that when the
risk-free asset is included,
you get that straight line.
And it's because the risk-free
asset has no covariance.
It has no risk at all.
But now, with an asset
that has a beta of 0,
you're getting the
risk-free return,
even though an asset
with a beta of 0
still may have some volatility.
It's not the risk-free asset.
It's any asset with a 0 beta.
The third observation
that I want to make
is when a beta is negative.
With the beta that's negative,
the expected rate of return
is actually less than
the risk-free rate.
Now that's really odd.
I've got an asset that is risky.
But just because it
has a negative beta,
the expected rate of return is
less than the risk-free rate.
That means that you are willing
to take a lower expected rate
of return than the risk-free
rate for an asset that
has this weird property
of negative beta.
And the question I want to
answer today is, why is that?
Why is it the case
that you might
be willing to take such
a low rate of return?
And actually, if the
beta is negative enough,
if this beta is
negative enough, it
could be the case that the
expected rate of return
is negative.
In other words, you might
be willing to pay somebody
for the privilege of
bearing that risk.
That seems completely
counterintuitive.
Why would you be willing
to pay to take risk?
You should be getting
paid to take risk, right?
That's the standard
hypothesis that we
come into the
financial markets with.
So yeah, Leah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: That's right.
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
That's exactly the intuition
for all three of these cases.
It turns out that the
beta, remember, has
this covariance term in there.
And it is going to
turn out that, if you
can find an asset that
is negatively correlated
to the tangency portfolio,
that is going to be
of tremendous value to you.
It's very, very valuable.
Now, OK.
Let me try to explain
the logic behind it.
And we're going to
do a few examples.
So let's go through the basic
logic of what's going on.
The tangency portfolio
plays a central role
in that everybody
in the world is
going to want to have
a portfolio that's
a combination of
the risk-free asset
and the tangency portfolio.
That's fact number one.
Fact number two, the tangency
portfolio is a portfolio that
has the aggregate measure
of the total amount of risk
in the economy that cannot be
diversified beyond that point.
In other words, in
order to get lower risk
than this particular
portfolio, you
have to decrease your
expected rate of return.
There's no way to get lower
risk and keep that same level
of expected return.
You can't go this way.
You have to go down this line.
OK?
So if you're going to
hold a portfolio of purely
risky securities,
then basically this
is the best that you can do.
This is the best
trade-off that you can
get in terms of risk-reward.
So right away you know
that this market portfolio
plays a very special role.
It is really the representation
of the aggregate risk
in the stock market.
And that's why it can serve as
a kind of a benchmark for what
the stock market is doing.
We're going to come back
to that benchmark idea
in a few minutes.
So, if you have a security
that is very highly
correlated to that
market return,
then that's not going
to help you in terms
of your own diversification.
If, on the other hand, you have
a security that is negatively
correlated with that
market portfolio,
that's going to help you a lot.
And if it's going
to help you a lot,
you're willing to pay for it.
When you're willing to pay
for it, what does that mean?
You drive the price today high.
And therefore, the
expected rate of return,
which is the return between
today and next period, that
becomes lower.
So an asset that
helps you hedge what
is essentially unhedgedgeable,
in other words, the market
portfolio, that can
benefit you a great deal.
As a result, it's
going to be very
hard to find negative
beta securities or assets.
But in any case, this
relationship really
tells you that, given a
particular covariance,
you can measure the
expected rate of return
that you ought to be getting.
And this relationship
is so important
that we give it a separate name.
It's called the security market
line, not the capital market
line, but the
security market line
because this applies to
every single security
in your entire universe.
Yeah, Dennis?
AUDIENCE: You say it's
hard to find something
with a negative beta.
But when you short
something, does
that mean you're
getting a negative beta?
ANDREW LO: It is.
You do.
But the problem with
shorting something
where you get a
negative beta, you also
get a negative expected
rate of return typically.
So what you want to
have is an asset that's
got a positive beta--
or negative beta,
but a positive expected
rate of return.
That's what's very rare.
But you can manufacture a
negative beta security very
easily by just shorting it.
The problem is that
when you short a stock,
you're going to also get a
very negative expected rate
of return.
And that doesn't
help you in terms
of producing an attractive
investment opportunity.
Ken, question?
AUDIENCE: So, what's an example
of a negative beta security?
ANDREW LO: Well, it's
very hard to come by.
But the closest thing that
exists in markets today
is stocks that are involved in
gold production, gold mining
stocks.
That has a beta of around 0,
but sometimes it's negative.
Sometimes it's positive.
But it's small.
So that's an example, but
that's about the only example
that we can come up
with in the data that
looks slightly negative.
By and large, most of the betas
in the data sets are positive.
And they're actually
clustered around 1.
So the typical beta is in the
neighborhood of 0.5 to 1.5.
All right.
Now, before we start
looking at the data--
I'm going to show you
some data in a minute--
I want to take the security
market line and apply it.
So the security market
line I did not derive.
I want to make that clear.
And for those of you who are
interested in the derivation,
you can take a look at the
appendix in the Brealey,
Meyers, and Allen.
They provide the derivation.
It's a little bit messy,
but with a little bit
of matrix algebra you
can work through it.
But the implications
are extremely important,
so I want all of you
to know how to use it.
So it may look pretty
simple, but I'll
show you a few applications that
you might not have thought of.
For example, suppose this is
true for every single security.
Well, if it's true for
every single security,
it turns out that this works
for portfolios as well.
And let me show you why.
Suppose you've got
a portfolio that's
a weighted average
of the returns
for the individual
components securities.
Then if I calculate
the covariance
between the portfolio return
and the tangency portfolio,
or the market, the
covariance is going
to look like this,
which is actually
just going to look
like a weighted average
of the covariances.
This is a mathematical identity,
from here down to here.
And therefore, when
I divide both sides
by the variance of the market,
I get something pretty neat,
which is that the
beta of my portfolio--
where beta is defined
as the covariance
between the portfolio
and the market divided
by the variance-- the
beta of the portfolio
is just equal to the
weighted average of the betas
of my component securities.
That's really neat
because what that says
is that, when I want to measure
the risk of a collection
of securities, as long
as I know the betas
of each individual
security, I can
calculate a weighted
average of those betas.
And that is the beta
of my portfolio.
So if you think of beta
as a measure of risk,
this measure of risk
is actually linear,
unlike volatility,
which is not linear.
The variance of a
portfolio is not simply
equal to the sum of
the variances weighted
by their portfolio weights.
It's that complicated
expression where
you're adding up all of
those cross products as well.
So we get an enormous
simplification
with the security market line.
It says that we can measure
the risk of a portfolio using
this concept called beta.
And beta happens to
be linear in the sense
that, when you take
a weighted average,
the beta is equal to
the weighted average
of the individual asset betas.
So therefore, if you
know that the betas are
going to be a weighted
average, then, in fact,
the expected rate of
return on the portfolio
now is equal to
the risk-free rate
plus this weighted average beta
times the market risk premium.
Do you see the power of this?
This now allows you to
analyze the expected return
on anything, any
collection of assets.
If you know what the betas are
for the individual components,
you know what the betas
are for the whole thing.
So now you can calculate the
appropriate rate of return
for virtually anything.
And this is not just
limited to stocks.
You can apply this to projects.
For example, if you
want to know what
the expected rate of return
is on an oil drilling project,
well, measure the beta of oil
drilling stocks, use that beta,
and that will be
appropriate discount
rate for that particular
oil drilling project.
It's a really remarkable result.
So we have an expression for
the required rate of return,
opportunity cost of capital,
risk-adjusted discount rate,
for all the various different
kind of examples and cases
that we looked at up until now.
And the last point I want
to make about this equation
is, how do you actually
take it out for a spin?
How do you estimate the
expected rate of return
on the market and
the risk-free rate?
Well, that comes from the data.
That comes from the marketplace.
We observe it in
the marketplace.
And we can actually see it.
OK.
So let's do some examples, just
to make sure that we all get
this and know how to apply it.
Using returns from
1990 to 2001, we
estimate that Microsoft's beta
during that period of time
is 1.49.
And if you do the same
thing for Gillette,
you get that Gillette's
beta is 0.81.
Now, let's not even look
at the next set of numbers
for a moment, and just talk
about those two numbers, 1.49
and 0.81.
Does that make sense to you?
Let's think about
what that's saying.
1.49 says that the
covariance between Microsoft
and the market
portfolio is actually
a lot higher than the
variance of the market itself.
So let me ask you to
think about whether or not
adding Microsoft
to your portfolio
is going to make it less
risky or more risky.
And here's how I want
you to think about it.
Remember what we said
about diversification.
When you hold a
collection of securities,
what matters more, the
variances or the covariances?
AUDIENCE: Covariances.
ANDREW LO: Right.
Why are the covariances
more important?
What's a quick and dirty way
of arguing that the covariances
matter more?
AUDIENCE: Because there
are n squared minus n.
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
There are a heck of a
lot more covariances
than there are variances.
You only got n variances
to worry about,
but you got n squared
minus n covariances.
And if they all line up
in the same direction,
you get the subprime
crisis problem, right?
So covariances matter
more than variances.
Well, if that's the case,
then when we look at a stock
and think about bringing
it into our portfolio,
we want to ask
the question, what
is it doing in terms of adding
or subtracting covariances
to our portfolio?
And one way to
measure whether or not
it's adding or subtracting
is to ask the question, what
is the covariance between
Microsoft and my stock
holdings?
Now what are your
stock holdings?
If everybody is a
rational investor--
by rational I mean
you like return
and you don't like risk--
then you know you're going to
be holding the risk-free rate
and the market portfolio.
You're going to be on
that capital market line.
So if you're a
rational investor,
the only stock holding you
have is that mutual fund,
m, the tangency portfolio.
So therefore, the most
important thing in your mind
is, when you think
about buying a new stock
and putting into your
portfolio, is this
going to be highly correlated
with my market portfolio?
Well, that's what beta measures.
Beta is a relative measure that
says, OK, the total variance
that you're holding in
risky securities, that's
sigma m squared.
That's the variance of
the market portfolio.
How does Microsoft
compare to that
in terms of what
it will contribute,
in terms of its covariance
with your holding?
So you're holding
one mutual fund,
and you're thinking
about adding Microsoft.
The only covariance that
you should care about
is the covariance
between Microsoft
and what you're holding.
Well, that's what beta measures.
If the number is greater
than 1, what it's saying
is that, when you bring
Microsoft into your portfolio,
you're going to be
increasing the variance
because the covariance,
which is what we care about,
is greater than the variance
of what you're holding.
If, on the other hand,
the beta is less than 1,
then, presumably,
that's helping you
because that's lowering the
variance relative to what
you're holding.
But helping or
hurting, that only
can be answered
directly if you explain
what you're getting in terms
of the expected rate of return.
So looking at beta by
itself is not enough.
Beta is a measure of risk.
It measures this
covariance divided
by the variance, or
covariance per unit
variance in the marketplace.
But you want to know what
the expected rate of return
is as well.
That's what the security
market line gives you.
OK.
Now let's get back
to the example.
Microsoft is a lot more
risky than the market.
It's about 49% more risky
according to this measure.
On the other hand,
Gillette is actually
less risky than the market.
Now do you guys buy that?
Does that pass the smell test?
Does that make sense?
Why?
What's the intuition for that?
Courtney?
AUDIENCE: Well, people don't
necessarily need computers.
And the technology is variable,
but Gillette sells razor
products and deodorant, which
is kind of a staple in a lot
of people's--
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
That's right.
If you make the argument that,
from 1990 to 2001, if there
are economic downturns,
what's the first
to go, razorblades or Windows?
Thankfully Windows.
[LAUGHTER]
Nowadays, I don't know the
answer to that actually.
Because nowadays, we depend
so much on the internet,
that actually it
could be different.
So I haven't updated
this analysis
to see what the beta
is from 2001 to 2008,
but it could be different.
So now we may have
unshaven geeks
that, you know,
during downturns--
and maybe it's flipped around.
Eduard?
AUDIENCE: Could you
give us an intuition?
Because beta allows
us to compute
the appropriate return
for a certain risk.
ANDREW LO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But what
is the intuition of,
how far away am I from
the efficiency portfolio?
So, how bad is this portfolio
compared to the efficient one?
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
So, that's a good question.
Let me go back to this
equation and take a look at it,
and try to provide even
more intuition for this
before we go on.
So the idea behind
this equation is
that it tells you that
this is the rate of return
that you should have if
you have a certain beta.
Now you can actually measure
the deviation from that
very simply by
asking the question.
For a portfolio manager
or an investment project
that yields an expected
rate of return that's
different from this,
that difference
is actually what we call alpha.
And alpha could be
positive or negative.
So when you say, how far
away are you from efficiency?
This gives you a direct measure
of how far away you are.
It's basically the difference
between the expected
rate of return you
have versus what
you're supposed to have given
the beta of the security.
But let me add one
more thing to that,
which is that beta is a measure
of a particular kind of risk
that a particular security has.
And the kind of risk,
as I said before,
is this covariance
between the rate
of return on a particular
asset and the rate of return
on the market portfolio.
This kind of risk is
not the total risk
of a particular security.
In fact, it is called
the systematic risk.
The systematic
risk is the portion
of the risk that is related
to the market portfolio.
So how far away you are
from efficiency really
depends upon how much
risk you have that is not
necessarily systematic risk.
Now, I don't expect you
to understand all of it
yet because I need to develop
a little bit more machinery.
But I'm going to get
back to that intuition
in just a few minutes, OK?
So I'm going to
give you a better
answer to your question than
what I just did because I'll
explain the difference
between systematic risk
and idiosyncratic risk.
And I think then it'll make
this completely transparent.
So give me another 15 minutes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned that gold stocks
can reduce the volatility.
They may have--
ANDREW LO: Historically it has.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So there are some
currencies that
are indexed to gold prices.
So let's say you're company x.
If you are listed in the Dow
Jones versus this country,
whose currency is
indexed to gold,
do you expect the company
that's listed in the gold index
currency to have a lower beta?
ANDREW LO: Well, it could.
But on the other
hand, the question
is, what are they doing to
try to hedge that currency
exposure?
In other words, if they end up
hedging all of that exposure,
then it doesn't
matter anymore, right?
So it depends.
But the idea is that, if it
has exposure to a 0 beta asset,
then you will find that the
ultimate fluctuations are
going to have less correlation
to the market portfolio.
Slomi?
AUDIENCE: Maybe Microsoft
has a bigger beta
because during this
period, the 10 years,
Microsoft was a [? growth ?]
company, and [INAUDIBLE]..
So this is the reason
why it has a bigger beta.
ANDREW LO: You know,
that's possible.
But remember that when
we estimate the beta,
we're estimating it
using monthly returns.
And so we're measuring
the covariance
on a month-to-month
basis, not just the trend.
We're measuring fluctuations
around that trend.
So the trend alone won't
necessarily explain all of it.
It has to also be the
fluctuations are actually
going both up and down,
higher than the variability
of the market portfolio.
Let me continue on
with the example.
And we're going to come back.
I'm going to show
how to estimate this,
and then you'll develop
more intuition from it.
So this makes sense from
the smell test in the sense
that Microsoft, at least
during that period of time,
was not necessarily something
that you would expect would
do well in good times and bad.
But something like razor
blades and shaving cream
we need to use regardless.
So that sort of tells us that
these betas look about right.
OK.
If you agree with
the betas, then it
turns out that we can
actually calculate
the required rate of return
for each of these two stocks.
So if you assume that
the risk-free rate is 5%,
which is what it was
about in that period--
not today obviously, but back
in that period, so about 5%.
And if, historically,
the risk premium,
as I told you last
time, is about 6%,
then when you do the
calculations using the security
market line, you get
a very sharp answer
to the question, what are the
appropriate discount rates
or costs of capital for
these two companies?
The answer, for Gillette, it's
about 9.86%, for Microsoft,
13.94%.
So now if you're sitting
in these companies
and you're asking
the question, we're
going to expand our operations,
but in order to do that,
we have to do an NPV calculation
to see whether it's worthwhile.
We have to compute the expected
net present value of expansion.
And in order to do that,
we've got estimates
of what our cash flows are
going to be for our expansion,
but we don't know what
the cost of capital is.
Well here's the answer for you.
You've actually got hard
numbers to plug in to your NPV
calculations now.
Now, there are a bunch of
assumptions that we've made.
So we're going to have
to go back and justify
those assumptions each and every
time you use this technology.
It's not physics.
This is not mathematics.
You're applying a set of
theories and approximations
to a much, much more
complex reality.
Every time you
apply it, you've got
to go back and ask the
question, does it make sense?
Do these assumptions hold?
And if so, great,
go ahead and use it.
If not, you've got to
go back and rederive
some of these analytics.
OK, so the security
market line is now
a line that describes
the expected return,
or required rate of return,
on an asset or a project
as a function of the riskiness,
where the riskiness is now
measured by beta, not by sigma.
It's not variance or
standard deviation
that measures the appropriate
risk for most projects.
Most projects, the way
you measure their risk
is not by sigma.
It turns out that the way
you measure their risk,
for the purposes of calculating
the required rate of return,
you measure it by beta.
OK?
That's a very deep insight.
It changes the way
we think about risk
and expected rate of return.
It's not to say that risk,
in terms of volatility,
doesn't matter.
Of course it does.
That is the basis of
this entire framework.
We started out by saying
that people don't like sigma,
and they do like mu.
They don't like variants.
They do like expected
rate of return.
That still holds.
But in doing so, when we derive
all of these implications, what
we find is that,
as an investor, you
don't get rewarded for taking
larger and larger amounts
of volatility necessarily.
You do get rewarded for taking
larger and larger amounts
of beta.
That's the sense in which beta
is a better measure of risk.
For the purposes of computing
the required rate of return,
beta is the right
measurement, not sigma.
The only cases where sigma is
the right measure of risk--
when I say right, I mean where
increases in sigma must imply
increases in the
required rate of return--
is when?
When is sigma the
right measure of risk
for the purposes of computing
the required rate of return?
For what kind of
securities or portfolios?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it for
efficient portfolios?
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
For efficient portfolios only.
Efficient portfolios meaning
these guys, meaning these guys.
Anything on this line, then
sigma is the right measure.
Sigma p over sigma m, that is
the right measure for any kind
of portfolio that is efficient.
But we know that the
typical security,
the typical project, the typical
division, is not efficient.
Efficient, again,
meaning you can get the--
you can't get any better
expected rate of return
for the same risk, or you can't
get a lower amount of risk
for the same expected
rate of return.
So for all of the inefficient
securities, portfolios,
or projects, you've got
to use this relationship,
and this relationship tells
you beta is what matters,
not sigma.
Sigma is not the same as
beta, except if you happen
to be an efficient portfolio.
OK.
Question-- do you
have a question?
No?
OK.
All right.
So here's an example of the
security market line at work.
And the slope of this
security market line
is, of course, the expected
rate of return on the market
minus the risk-free rate.
And the idea behind the
security market line
is that, no matter
what your beta is,
you've got a required
rate of return that's
determined by this slope.
And now, to answer Eduard's
question about deviations
and how far away you
are from efficiency
if you deviate from this line,
then the vertical distance
is the alpha of your portfolio
or project or investment
opportunity.
If markets are working
exactly the way they should,
then you're on this line.
You're always on this line.
And if you're Warren Buffett,
you're off of this line.
You've got a very
large, positive alpha.
So if you've got skill, if
you can forecast markets,
then you will do
better than this.
But what this framework tells
you is that even if you cannot
forecast markets, even if
you don't know what's going
to happen next year
to stock prices,
you should still do as well as
what this line suggests that
you can do.
OK?
On average, this line should
be achievable by everybody
that understands the
basics of portfolio theory.
Now, as I said, the
performance evaluation approach
to using the
security market line
is just a measure of
the vertical distances.
And it can lead to some
interesting results.
For example, here
are three managers.
All three of these managers have
a 15% expected rate of return.
But they have different betas.
And so the question
is, if you had
money to put into
these managers,
which would you choose?
Well, clearly you
would choose manager A
because the manager
is only supposed
to have a 6% rate of return,
but, in fact, he's offering 15
for that level of risk.
Manager B is just
basically doing
what you would expect the
manager should be doing.
And manager C is
actually underperforming.
Given the risk that manager
C is exposing you to,
manager C should be doing
much better than he is.
And by the way, notice that
I've said that the same--
all three managers have
the same volatility, 20%.
You can have the same volatility
but have different betas.
Betas and volatilities do not
necessarily go hand in hand.
There is actually a relationship
between beta and volatility.
We'll talk about that
in a little while.
But that relationship is not
nearly as straightforward
as you might think.
Ingrid?
AUDIENCE: Can you estimate a
future return of a mutual fund
by [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, I understand
it's the best you can do,
but how realistic is it?
ANDREW LO: Well, so it
depends on who you are.
If you are a typical
index fund manager,
you would argue that
mutual funds are basically
going to provide you with a
relatively stable expected rate
of return over time.
So in other words, it'll
fluctuate up and down
because it's got some
variance, but there
is a baseline expected
rate of return
that a mutual fund offers you.
And that's what
people are buying.
When you put your money
in an emerging market
equity mutual fund, you're
going to have a higher
return on average, on average,
than if you put your money
in a S&P 500 index fund.
Why are you going to have
a higher rate of return
on average?
Because you're going be
bearing more risk on average.
The only way to convince you to
put your money in an emerging
market fund is if it does
have that higher expected rate
of return on average.
So what you're basing these
kinds of calculations on
is not that I can forecast
what mutual funds are going
to do next year, but
rather, mutual funds
offer expected rate of returns
that are stable over time.
So what happened last year and
the year before and the year
before that, when you
average it all together,
it's about what you're going to
get over the next five years.
That's it.
That's the argument.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Yes.
We don't know-- right, exactly.
So there is a very large
idiosyncratic component
that fluctuates year
by year, and who
knows what that could be.
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Last
time, when you were
describing more [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW LO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You had mentioned
that for more risk people
will expect more return,
but not necessarily
proportional to the--
so you end up having a line
that just goes up exponentially,
right?
Because you had given
the analogy that, OK,
now to get investors
to be in more risk,
to take on more risk, you have
to offer a lot more than just
[INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW LO: Well, you may.
But the equilibrium
theory that we've argued
has to hold actually says
that the risk-reward trade-off
is, in fact, linear for
efficient portfolios.
If it's not for efficient
portfolios, then who knows?
But the theory of the
capital asset pricing
model, or the security
market line, which
is what we derive-- what we
what we talked about today,
this says that, in
fact, it is linear.
So in other words, this
result, as I told you,
we didn't derive it,
but it's a major result
that shows that the relationship
between risk and expected
return, where risk is measured
by beta now, is linear.
This is a linear relationship.
So this is a major advance
that we didn't expect.
And, in fact, so what I showed
before was the preferences.
So in other words, we talked
last time about the situation
where, suppose that
you're an investor,
and I start you off
at a point like this.
And I ask the
question, if I want
you to tell me where
you're going to be such
that you're just as well off.
You have the same
level of utility.
That curve, that
indifference curve,
is going to look
something like this.
That's going to be curved.
That's what you're
talking about.
But that's the behavior
of one individual.
The point about the
CAPM is that if you
aggregate all of the individuals
together and ask the question,
what does the expected rate
of return and volatility
or expected rate of
return and beta look like?
How are they related?
In fact, it's magical that
it actually is linear.
So it's exactly the fact that
we didn't expect linearity.
Given that there are
diminishing marginal returns
to risk and reward, you
wouldn't expect linearity.
But, in fact, it drops out.
I mean, this drops out of this
tangency portfolio argument,
right?
Nothing up my sleeve,
this was an argument
that we all did together.
And we derived this curve
from first principles.
So this is really an
astounding result,
but it's even more
astonishing that you
get this result
for all securities,
not just for
efficient portfolios.
OK, other questions?
All right.
Let's do another example.
So here I want to show you how
you can use the security market
line, also called
the CAPM, C-A-P-M,
for Capital Asset Pricing Model.
I want to show you
how you can use it
to do performance attribution.
This is the data from
a real live hedge fund
manager, who will go nameless
since I don't want to get
sued by him for any reason.
Hedge fund managers are both
very wealthy, typically,
and also very
litigious, so you want
to be careful when you
talk about them in public.
Hedge fund XYZ had an average
annualized return of 12.5%
and a return standard
deviation of 5.5% from January
'85 to December 2002, and the
estimated beta over this period
was minus 0.028.
Now, somebody asked
about a negative beta.
Well here's an example
of a negative beta asset.
Positive expected rate
of return, negative beta.
So if it's got a
positive expected return
and a negative beta, you
know something can't exactly
be right because that doesn't
sound like it makes sense
in terms of the CAPM framework.
And, in fact, it doesn't.
It doesn't make sense.
Well, let's do the math.
The expected the
rate of return is
equal to Rf plus beta times
the market risk premium.
Market risk premium of
6%, risk-free rate of 5%,
plug that in with the
beta of minus 0.028,
and you get that
this manager should
have earned 4.83% per year.
That's what the manager
should have earned.
In fact, the manager earned
a rate of return of 12.%
per year.
So that's an alpha.
If you define the alpha as
what the manager did earn minus
what the manager
should have earned,
you've got an alpha of
771 basis points per year.
That's a humongous alpha.
Very, very big amount
of excess performance.
This is why people are
excited about hedge funds.
Now, we're not going to talk
in great detail about it
in this course because it goes
beyond the scope of Finance
401.
But in an investments
course, the next level
of sophistication would
be to take a look at this
and say, OK, is this
alpha really alpha,
or is it due to other factors,
other risks that we're not
measuring?
Right now the only
risk we're measuring
is this tangency portfolio
risk, this beta risk.
But maybe there are
multiple betas out there.
We're not going to talk
about it in this course,
but in 433 you will discuss it.
And it will turn out
that hedge funds actually
do have multiple betas.
So you shouldn't go out and put
all your money in hedge funds
right away because this
extra performance, some of it
is due to true genius and
insight and unique skill.
But part of it is
also due to the fact
that you're bearing risks that
you had no idea you're bearing.
And so you've got to be careful
about getting on the bandwagon
and saying, yeah, give
me some hedge funds.
I want some of this alpha.
Anon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
But how do we know
this is good for the investor?
Because they could have invested
in the asset [INAUDIBLE]..
ANDREW LO: So the
question is, how do we
know that this is actually
good for the investor?
Because they could have gotten
some returns from the S&P.
The way we know that
is because we're
measuring the expected rate
of return relative to the S&P.
So in other words, the
way I got this number,
this is the excess
return on the S&P.
That's what the market
risk premium is.
So in fact, given the
beta of this manager,
it should have only
given you 4.83%
return relative to what the
S&P would have given you,
which is a 6% excess
rate of return.
And, in fact, what we see is
that this manager produced
a 12% rate of
return, or 7% above
and beyond what it was
supposed to have done.
So this takes that into account.
What it doesn't
take into account
is how much liquidity risk the
hedge fund manager is taking,
how much currency risk,
how much commodity risk,
and a bunch of other risks
that are not represented
by the tangency portfolio.
Megan?
AUDIENCE:
[? When you hear about ?]
looking out for beta
dressed up as alpha,
it's really because there
are multiple sources of beta
that aren't getting
wrapped into that.
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
That's exactly right.
Recently, a lot of
institutional investors
have become skeptical
of hedge funds
because they say,
hedge funds alpha
is really dressed up data.
In other words,
hedge fund managers
are taking risks
that are not captured
by this very simple framework.
And so when you run
these kind of regressions
and do this analysis, you're
getting tremendous alpha,
but in fact, it's not all alpha.
There's other kinds
of betas in there.
And so there's a
whole literature
that has developed
about multiple,
what are called exotic,
betas or alternative betas.
Again, not part of the
scope of introductory
finance, but it is something
that's covered in investments.
Just another illustration of
what this hedge fund has done.
Take a look at the
growth of $1 invested
in the hedge fund over
the last 20 years,
and you'll see that the
blue line is the hedge fund.
The red line is the S&P 500.
So to your point, Anon, the
S&P 500 gave you a wild ride.
And so for a while
you were doing better
than the hedge fund, but,
in fact, now this hedge fund
has done quite a bit better.
Now this ends in 2002.
I'll give you a little
bit of an update.
I don't have it
here in the graph,
but you can use
your imagination.
It turns out that up
to 2007, the blue line
is way ahead of the red line.
That's actually changed in 2008.
This hedge fund has done
very badly this year.
Of course, the S&P
has done even worse.
So the gap is not as
wide as it used to be.
There's still a gap, but the
gap is actually narrowed a bit.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] The
risk-free rate is changing.
The market rate
is changing, so--
ANDREW LO: No.
In fact, everything is changing.
So if you want to
take seriously change,
you've basically got to figure
out how the risk-free rate is
changing, the expected
rate of return is changing,
and the betas actually
are also changing.
But what I'm trying to do
with a simple illustration
is use a long period and
say, over that entire period,
let's average across
all of these changes.
Justin?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
If you look at the graph
and it seems like the
differences of the graph
were just higher
with the market.
ANDREW LO: It is, but you
don't adjust for the beta.
That's the key, right?
The S&P has a beta of 1.
This guy, this
hedge fund manager,
has a beta of 0 or
slightly negative.
That's the difference.
That's why looking at
volatility can be misleading.
If you look at
volatility, you'd say,
well, you know, obviously
the S&P has done better.
But keep in mind that look
how smooth the blue line is.
And the lesson of the
CAPM is that investors
pay for smoothness, but only
a certain kind of smoothness.
In other words, smoothness
means low volatility, right?
The smoothest line,
of course, is T-bills.
That's a straight line.
That will go sort of like this.
And investors are not
going to pay a lot for that
because that doesn't
really help them generate
expected rate of return.
If you've got expected rate of
return and smoothness together,
you get a really big, big alpha.
And that's exactly what we see
here, an alpha of 771 basis
points.
Now, here I talk about
these multiple sources
of systematic risk.
I don't want to focus
on that for this course
because, as I said, it's going
to be much more complicated
and requires more machinery.
But the basic
intuition is the same.
Instead of just one
source of systematic risk,
you may have multiple sources.
And so therefore, you're
going to have multiple risk
premia as opposed to just one.
But for now, let's
not focus on that.
And we're going to
focus our attention just
on this simple equation, and
make sure we understand it
and know how to apply it.
Now, I want to go--
I want to give you one
more intuition for why
it is that beta is the
appropriate measure of risk,
and not sigma, for arbitrary
inefficient portfolios.
And the idea is
actually pretty simple.
When you think of an
investment like Microsoft
or like Gillette, you can think
of the risk of that portfolio
as being--
the risk of that investment
in those individual securities
as having two components.
So when you think of the
volatility of Gillette,
you can think of the
volatility of Gillette
coming from two sources.
One source is the aggregate
risk that affects all companies.
And the second source
of risk is the risk
unique to Gillette,
the fact that they've
got a particular manufacturing
plant in a particular location
of the country, the
fact that they've
got a specific set of managers
that are either good or bad,
the fact that they
are subject to a very
specific set of requirements
for producing their blades,
who knows, but very
specific to that company.
When you think about
that kind of risk,
let me ask you a question from
a purely business perspective.
You're the investor.
I'm a representative
of Gillette.
I'm trying to sell you
my company's stock.
I want you to invest
in my company.
And therefore, I have to pay you
to take the risk of Gillette.
If I tell you that Gillette
has these two pieces of risk--
so I'm the representative from
Gillette and I tell you that
our company is subject to
economy-wide fluctuations that
will help or hurt our business
and unique fluctuations that
are specific and
special to Gillette--
which of these two
risks are you going
to be more concerned about
from your investment portfolio
perspective?
Rami?
AUDIENCE: I think you'd
be more concerned about--
as a portfolio as a whole,
you look at the economy,
but I think, for this
specific purpose,
[INAUDIBLE] you obviously
will pick Gillette-specific--
ANDREW LO: OK.
But I want-- you hurried
through the first point,
and I want you to expand
on that a little bit.
You said that if you're worried
about your portfolio, then
obviously the economy-wide risk.
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
If you're worried about
the economy-wide risk,
and for example, over the
next two, three years,
you don't think the economy
is going to recover,
then you're going to just
avoid that type of investment
as a whole.
ANDREW LO: OK.
OK, fine.
But on the other hand, you
also said something else,
which is that if you're
comparing between two stocks,
then what you're focusing
on is the risks that
are unique to Gillette.
AUDIENCE: You also might look at
how much the economic downturn
would affect a
company like Gillette.
ANDREW LO: Right.
AUDIENCE: So if the economic
downturn, as you said before,
affects Microsoft greater
than it would Gillette,
and you suspect something
is going to happen,
you'd go for Gillette.
If, on the other hand,
you didn't suspect that,
you might go for--
ANDREW LO: OK.
But let's now talk
about the negotiations
between you and me.
I'm a representative
of Gillette.
I'm trying to get you
to invest with us.
And I've got two
sources of risk that you
might be concerned about, market
risk or Gillette-specific risk.
From your portfolio
perspective, since you just
care about maximizing the
value of your portfolio,
you're not worried about
Gillette in particular.
You're not management.
You're an investor.
I'm management.
I'm worried about Gillette.
I couldn't care less about your
portfolio, I'm sorry to say.
What I care about is my
company, but what you care about
is your portfolio.
From your portfolio
perspective, what
are you going to care more
about, Gillette-specific risk
or the macroeconomic risk that
I represent to your portfolio?
AUDIENCE: When I'm
talking to you,
I care more about
your specific risks.
ANDREW LO: Well, I'm
asking a question though
about your portfolio.
What you care about
is your portfolio.
I understand that when
you're talking to me,
you're going to be asking me
about my company-specific risk
to try to get a handle on it.
But is that what
you ultimately are
going to be concerned about?
AUDIENCE: I would be
concerned about, obviously,
the macro portion of it
and how you fit into that.
But I'd look at
your beta and see--
ANDREW LO: You don't
know the CAPM, though.
So now you're cheating
because you now know the CAPM.
But suppose you didn't.
What I'm trying to get
at is the intuition,
a businessman's
intuition, for what
you would care
about more in terms
of what I do to your portfolio.
Yeah, Sema?
AUDIENCE: Didn't you
say, two lectures ago,
that the idiosyncratic risk
is [? their survival? ?]
ANDREW LO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, you care more
about systematic risk--
ANDREW LO: Why?
AUDIENCE: Because only one
[INAUDIBLE] in my portfolio.
ANDREW LO: That's exactly right.
The idea is that if
it's Gillette-specific
risk, then by
definition, if you're
holding a well-diversified
portfolio,
then you're not going to care
about that because that's going
to average out to nothing.
Now, of course, we have
to think about the case
where you're not holding
a diversified portfolio,
but let me get back
to that in a minute.
I'm assuming that all of you
are good business folks, which
means that you're
going to be holding
a diversified portfolio.
You're not going to
concentrate all your bets
on one particular kind
of investment, right?
So if you are already holding
a very well-diversified
portfolio, then when
you interview me
as a potential
investment opportunity,
do you really care about
the idiosyncratic risk?
Because that risk is going
to be diversified away.
What you care about from a
portfolio perspective is,
how much am I going
to be contributing
to your overall risk?
And now that you know the CAPM,
you understand the logic of it.
It says, you care about my beta
because my beta is a measure
of the amount of risk I'm going
to be adding to your portfolio
that you cannot get rid of.
How do you know you
cannot get rid of it?
Well, by definition it's
the market portfolio.
Everybody's holding it.
Nobody wants to get
rid of it completely.
You're on the capital
market's line.
That's the best you can do.
So this notion of
firm-specific risk
versus economy-wide
risk, that distinction
is a really important one.
And I'll show you the
mathematics of it in a minute,
but I want to give
you the intuition.
As a result, think
about this conversation
happening not just for
Gillette, but for every company
in the economy.
If it's the case that portfolio
managers that are buying stocks
only care about the systematic
risk, about the market risk,
about the risk that they cannot
get rid of, and then you have
to reward them for that, then
what that means is that you
don't have to reward them
for idiosyncratic risk.
Why?
Because that's not risk
that you are forced to bear.
There's nothing
that says you have
to bear idiosyncratic risk.
How do you get rid
of idiosyncratic
risk if you don't
want to bear it?
Diversify.
Exactly.
Just buy 10 stocks
instead of one,
and then you're diversified.
20 stocks is better than 10.
And mathematically,
after 50 stocks,
you're basically diversified.
You're done.
So nobody should be holding
two or three stocks.
Or if they do, they are bearing
risk that they need not bear.
And they may want to do
it for other reasons.
For example, as a
manager of Gillette,
I believe in the company.
I want to demonstrate
to my shareholders
that I'm tied to
the company, so I'm
going to hold a lot of my
wealth in Gillette stock.
That's not well diversified.
I'm holding a lot of
Gillette-specific risk.
That's not a smart thing
to do from an investment
point of view, but
that is a smart thing
to do from a management
point of view
because I'm tying my fate
to the fate of the company.
It's definitely not a smart
thing from an investments
perspective.
If you're in a financial
services sector,
you should not be buying
financial services stocks.
If you're in the
pharmaceutical sector,
you should not be
buying biotech stocks.
And yet we do that for
reasons other than portfolio
management.
But given that I'm teaching
you about portfolio management,
I'm not going to focus
on those other reasons.
If this were an
organizational studies course,
you'd be getting a
different perspective.
And you should get a
But for the purposes of
building financial wealth, what
you want to do is
to focus on how
much the systematic component
is contributing to your risk,
because the
idiosyncratic component
you don't have to bear.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So like an employee
purchase plan, where,
if you're in financial
services, you're
working for a
mutual fund company,
and they offer you 10%,
15% you put your salary in,
and you can buy stock--
ANDREW LO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Would you
recommend not doing that?
ANDREW LO: Well, I
recommend not doing it
from the financial
perspective, but I
may recommend doing it
from the management,
or managerial
incentives, perspective.
The reason that companies
do that is very simple.
They're trying to suck you in.
They're trying to get you
to be more intimately tied
to the company so you'll act
like an owner of the company,
as opposed to an employee.
And if you act
like an owner, you
will engage in behavior
that is much more
productive for building
the company's wealth,
rather than as an employee.
But from your
personal perspective,
you're bearing risk
that you don't need to.
So you know, the
analogy that I give--
I've given before-- it
may work for some of you.
It may not.
Let me explain.
Anybody know how much window
washers in midtown Manhattan
get paid on an annual basis?
You know what I'm talking about?
These are the folks that climb
up on these two-foot catwalks
that are 40 stories high,
and they wash the windows
of these skyscrapers.
That's a pretty risky job.
Anybody know what
their annual salary
is, when you annualize it?
I actually decided
to find out one day.
I was kind of curious about
that because, you know,
there's a trade-off
of risk and return.
And that's really risky.
You know, there was one day
when I was staying at a hotel.
I think it was the Millennium,
and I was on the 30th floor,
and it was a windy winter day.
And, sure enough, there was
somebody there pulling up
the thing, cleaning the window,
and looked happy as can be.
You know, no problem.
And I was thinking, boy, this
guy's taking a lot of risk,
you know?
And I hope he's
getting paid for it.
And these salaries
are determined
by supply and demand.
What do you think it would be?
Anybody have a guess?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: About $70,000.
ANDREW LO: $70,000, OK.
Anybody else?
Justin?
AUDIENCE: $125,000.
ANDREW LO: $125,000?
[LAUGHTER]
That's higher than some
NBA starting salaries.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Leah?
AUDIENCE: $30,000.
ANDREW LO: $30,000.
AUDIENCE: Do they take interns?
ANDREW LO: Insurance?
Interns.
I don't know about that.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, so when I looked
last time, which
is about four years
ago, it turns out
that the typical window
washer for these skyscrapers
gets paid about $60,000
a year, annual salary.
$60,000.
Now, you know, I
don't know whether you
think that's a lot or a little.
But, seems to me that
that compensation reflects
the kind of risk that
we're talking about.
And you know, you have no
educational requirements,
no degrees, no certifications.
You just show up and,
you know, up you go.
Now let me ask you a question.
Suppose that a
window washer comes
to the job who happens
to really enjoy dancing
while he washes windows.
In particular, he
dances that, you know,
the Irish jig or whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
You know what I'm talking about?
You know, that
dancing, the very--
and he just likes to do that
while he's washing windows
on the 40th floor.
You agree that that's
more risky, right?
Do you think that that
particular individual gets
paid more than $60,000 a year?
Why?
He's taking more risk.
Why not?
Why isn't he getting paid more?
Exactly.
He doesn't have
to take that risk.
That's not part of the job.
He can choose to take
that risk, but he's not
going to get compensated for
it because it's not necessary.
And there are 100,000 people
behind him waiting in line
to get that job that
won't necessarily
need to take that risk.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I thought
of it differently.
If you had a long,
short portfolio,
would it be the
other way around?
Because you wouldn't care
about the market risk.
You can hedge that out.
You're thinking only
about specific risk.
So like in that case, I would
short the guy who likes to jig.
And I would invest in
the guy who didn't.
ANDREW LO: Well, that
depends on whether or not
doing the Irish
jig actually makes
you wash windows
better or worse,
in other words, where there's
an alpha to that risk.
It may be the case that
dancing the Irish jig
actually helps you
scrape off dirt
that much more effectively.
In which case, you may
not want to short him
because then he will earn a
premium in certain markets.
Those with lots of pigeon
poop on the windows.
[LAUGHTER]
So we can get into this analogy
more deeply than we should.
[LAUGHTER]
But the point is that, when
you think about the CAPM,
all it's saying is that
you get what you pay for.
And you pay for what you get.
In other words, if there
is a certain amount of risk
in a particular investment
that is risk that nobody
can get rid of easily--
in other words, you
have to bear it--
then you have to pay for it.
Because otherwise people
aren't going to do it.
However, if there's risk
in a particular company
that you don't have to pay for,
that you don't have to take,
then you don't
have to pay for it.
That's all that
the CAPM is saying.
Beta is a measure of that
hard little pellet of risk
that you can't get rid of.
And the variance is the
measure of the entire risk
in a particular portfolio.
The only case where variance
and beta are the same
is for what kind of portfolio?
An efficient portfolio.
What is an efficient portfolio?
It's one that is already
maximally diversified.
By adding more
securities, you are not
going to do any better
than that straight line.
All of these portfolios have
been completely diversified.
How do I know that?
Because you're at the
tangency portfolio.
There is nowhere to
go in the Northwest
region off of that line.
So for all of these securities,
the sigma and the beta
are literally numerically
identical because there
is no more extra risk
in the portfolio.
It's been diversified away.
But for Gillette, for Microsoft,
for IBM, General Motors,
and Motorola, each of these
contain both beta risk
and non-beta risk.
The non-beta risk
is that Irish jig
that you don't have to do
while you're washing windows.
And you're not going to get
paid for it, I'm sorry to say.
So the relationship that
you want to focus on
is the capital asset pricing
model's security market line.
Measure the stuff that
you're going to get paid for.
And this is what you're
going to get paid for it.
Yeah, Ingrid?
AUDIENCE: When you go back
into the sort of the real world
and include transaction
costs, how do they enter here?
ANDREW LO: Well, so there
have been versions of the CAPM
with transactions cost.
And it turns out that it
doesn't change things too much.
If you impose transactions
cost on all securities,
and say that
there's a percentage
cost for going in and
out, you can derive a net
of fee transactions costs.
It won't affect the
pricing necessarily.
What it will affect is
the dynamics, the trading.
What it will mean is that you
will rebalance your portfolios
less frequently than
you otherwise might.
But there is still going
to be a relationship
between the net of
fee transactions
costs of these securities.
So you can actually look
at the transactions cost
as a way to deduct the
expected rate of return
from each of these securities.
So transactions cost
is not a big issue,
but there are other
issues that I'll
come to that will be
a problem for this.
AUDIENCE: Looking at this,
[INAUDIBLE] one of the best,
efficient portfolio that I can
have is basically the index.
If I want to allocate
my money globally,
should I buy indexes
according to the market
capital of the market?
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This is the most
efficient portfolio I would--
ANDREW LO: Right, so
that's a great question.
And we actually have a separate
course on international finance
that deals just with
those kind of issues
because they're so tricky.
But I'll give you
the short answer.
According to the theory,
this tangency portfolio
is not just for the
US stock market.
It should be for the world
stock market, everything.
So this tangency
portfolio should not
be the S&P 500 or
the Russell 2000,
it should be the
MSCI, or EAFE, index
that has all of the assets
in the world weighted
relative to their market cap
in that particular currency
of the investor that
you happen to be.
So if you're a US investor,
it'll be in dollars.
If you're a Brazilian
investor, it'll be in real.
It'll be in whatever
currency you trade in.
But that presupposes
that there's
capital market integration
throughout the world.
So in other words, if I call
this the world portfolio,
implicitly I'm
assuming that you're
free to trade stocks in any
part of the world freely.
There are no
barriers to trading.
And we know that
that's not the case.
There are barriers, in fact.
So what that means is
that the CAPM, applied
to international stocks, is an
approximation that may actually
be worse than applying
it country by country
and then looking to see
whether there are any distances
or discrepancies across
those different countries.
But people have come up
with international versions
of the CAPM.
And they don't work very well.
At least, they didn't
as of 10 years ago.
Within the last 10
years, a lot has changed.
So it could be that
capital market integration
has made the world
CAPM look a lot better
in terms of the data.
OK.
Other questions?
All right.
So now I'm going to talk
about implementing it.
And we're going to deal
with all of the messy issues
that I tried to put
off a lecture ago.
How do you take this
thing out for a spin?
Well, one thing you
could do is to try
to test the CAPM
to see if it works.
And one way to test it
is to ask the question,
if we assume that all
securities are priced according
to this equation, then another
way to write the equation that
doesn't rely on expected
returns, but relies
on realized returns, is to write
it as a regression equation,
as you did in DMD.
The regression equation is the
return, the actual realized
return on security i, is
given by the risk-free rate
plus beta times the realized
return on the market
minus the risk-free
rate plus epsilon.
Epsilon is the error term,
the disturbance, the residual,
that is giving you
the fluctuations
around the expected value.
So when we remove the expected
values from this equation,
we have to stick in
this epsilon term that
sort of bounces around.
By the way, when you
look at this equation,
you now have an
explicit representation
for systematic risk
and idiosyncratic risk.
For a given return,
it's comprised
of three pieces, the risk-free
rate, beta times the market
return that bounces around, and
this epsilon is the Irish jig.
That is the idiosyncratic
bouncing around
that you don't get
any reward for.
How do you know you don't
get any reward for it?
Because on average, the expected
value of this is equal to 0.
How do I know that?
By definition that's how I got
from this equation down here.
If you take the expected
value of this equation,
the only way that the
expected value of this
gives you this
equation on the top
is if that epsilon has a 0 mean.
So you don't get paid
for bearing epsilon risk.
It's there.
And for some stocks it's huge.
But you don't get paid
for it because you
don't have to bear it.
And the reason you
don't have to bear it
is, if you take
50 of these stocks
and stick them in a portfolio,
the epsilons average out to 0.
How do I know that?
Well, this relies on
a piece of mathematics
that's known as the
law of large numbers.
You may have heard that term
used in casual conversation,
but it's actually
a real theorem.
What it says is that
when you have large,
large numbers of
fluctuations that are not
correlated with each other--
and by definition,
idiosyncratic risks
for Gillette and Microsoft
and other companies
are not correlated because
they're idiosyncratic.
They're unique to those firms.
That when you get a large
number of these uncorrelated
fluctuations, that in the
limit, they actually go to 0.
You can disregard them.
So the law of large
numbers is what
tells you that this
idiosyncratic risk is not
going to be something
you will get paid for.
So this is the CAPM
relationship using actual data.
And if we stick in an alpha term
to represent deviations from
the CAPM, and I subtract the
risk-free rate from both sides,
just to have everything
in excess returns,
then the CAPM reduces to the
hypothesis that the alpha--
across all stocks, all
managers, all projects,
the alpha is equal to 0.
That's what the CAPM says.
And if you want to
formulate it strictly
in terms of total
rates of return,
it says that the alpha has to
be equal to the risk-free rate
times 1 minus beta.
This is a different
alpha than this alpha.
This alpha represents the
excess rate of return.
OK, so let's do it.
Let's see whether
or not it's true.
Let's take a bunch of stocks,
subtract the risk-free rate
from the stock returns, run
a regression of that stock's
return on a constant and
the market excess return,
and let's see whether the
intercept is equal to 0.
Well, if you do this for two
stocks, Biogen and Motorola--
I've done this from
1988 to I think 2006.
When you run that regression,
here's what you get.
For Biogen, the beta is
1.43, the intercept 1.61%,
and the standard error is 1.1%.
And then Rf times 1
minus beta is minus 2.1%.
This should be equal to the
alpha in that previous equation
that I gave you.
So in other words, the alpha
that we've estimated for Biogen
using this CAPM
regression is 3.7%,
or on a monthly basis 45% alpha.
Biogen is an incredibly good
buy according to the CAPM,
if you believe the CAPM.
All right.
Now that's Biogen.
What about Motorola?
During the same period,
when you estimate Motorola,
it's got a beta of 1.42.
And we're estimating an alpha
not quite as big, but 23.5%
percent on an annualized basis.
That's still pretty big.
So if you run this
regression and analyze it,
this is what you would
conclude, that these two stocks
are wonderful buys.
What we're going to
talk about next time
is whether this interpretation
really makes sense,
or whether we've got
some missing factors,
or whether we're measuring
things improperly.
We're going to need
to do a bit more work.
But we're very close to
being able to figure out
exactly how all of
these pricing models
work in tandem with the kinds
of risk budgeting calculations
that we're going to need to
do for the rest of the course.
So I'll see you on Monday.